lucky enough to be very restless they
some people call it a DD the economy's
bad and I'm not gonna get a job well
tough school is like a system isn't it
and for me I couldn't do it their way
I'm his third grade speller
I had to do it my way what always
baffled me is why I didn't have more
people across the street competing with
me and I would say if you're not
drinking enough beer at the Oasis you're
not taking advantage of your education
if you're always doing what you didn't
do yesterday you're never too ready to
get to do today's work let alone
tomorrow's the only reason you have
management is to remove obstacles not to
make obstacles do you know the secret
elixir of life is sleep I had to trust
people I trust the people because I
wasn't capable to do things myself and
you can't lead other people unless you
manage yourself he co-founded the copy
chain Kinkos Fortune magazine named
Kinkos to be one of the best places in
America to work for three years in a row
now that he is no longer the CEO of
Kinkos he's focused his efforts on
philanthropy he's Paul or Philip and
here his top 10 rules for success lucky
enough to be very restless they some
people call it a BD and I was very good
at leaving my business I after the first
three months we hired a manager because
I had those stores used to drive me nuts
they were very hectic and nerve-wracking
and my job was really because of my
restlessness and I could be in the
moment
was going store at a store to store
looking for what people are doing right
and exploiting it could I make a lot
more money discovering some cool new
idea than hovering in that office and
worrying about stuff and I was working
with very capable people that knew how
to run the business very well I had good
financial controls but my job was always
looking for ideas to make it better and
I used to find my job that everything
went beautifully without me but whatever
I did every day I made it better you're
surrounded by success I was thinking
about a washing machine washing machine
weighs maybe 150 pounds you buy it for
$750 isn't that an amazing thing $5.00 a
pound you get all those little parts it
suddenly seems a break
and that kind of amazing thing now you
get that whole washing machine for five
bucks a pound and that kind of a cool
deal are you aware that you are
surrounded by success every time you're
buying something is a successful
endeavor do you see the success around
you and are you obsessed with making
money from the success around you are
you obsessed with what's wrong like you
could sit in your office and now y'all
have a great cop-out the economy's bad
and I'm not gonna get a job well tough
you've got that cop-out for the rest of
your life that's not going to be if you
want to have that you could
intellectually be very honest and you
could sit at the Oasis and just become
an alcoholic I mean really you have that
intellectual option because you see the
job markets bad I'm just gonna go to
depression isn't that fair that's an
honest response but I would say maybe
you ought to just think about all the
gifts you have let's say the world is
successful I want to be part of it but I
don't want to work for other people
maybe that's like think why you're here
is that right
I'm really lucky I can't read well I
have no mechanical ability I was held
back from two grades I was expelled from
work for high schools I was graduated
eight from the bottom of my class of
1200 I figured out how to go through
college because I didn't want to want to
get drafted and if you think if it
schools like a system isn't it and for
me I couldn't do it their way I was
third grade speller I had to do it my
way and I think then getting through
that system prepares you for life and
how to get through that system and when
you think of it business is really
defining making your own rules to a
certain extent I don't know
nowadays if rejection is part of your
everyday life so I think a lot of
business and doing things is just the
idea of having resilience I'm gonna ask
y'all a question if your little five
year old comes to you with a painting
from school what are you gonna say
absolutely the worst thing you can say
because what you do by saying good job
is you teach a child the police others
ran the please themselves what you might
want to say is tell me about the
painting and why did you do it but I
think we'll producing I don't know if
today people are risk takers they want a
lot of attaboys and you have to get it
from within sooner or later so I am Not
sure guy amplifying a little bit
absolutely please here I am I am at USC
and it's really not complicated I saw
these people in line
Xerox ooh what a discovery if they're
xeroxing at USC why wouldn't they Xerox
at Santa Barbara was this such research
I didn't invent the Xerox machine they
were just in line Xerox II and it at one
point I mean all the customers could see
I have all the customers in line my own
workers could see how much money I was
taking it and I was in every we expanded
every college in America what always
baffled me is why I didn't have more
people across the street to beaten with
me and I think even back then you were
twisted we were risk takers but look
back on your grandparents if your
grandparents had seen that I had
something good with customers in line do
you think they would have been out there
competing with me in a heartbeat so I'm
not sure risk-taking is as rewarded as
it should be you fall all over somebody
here you don't love him here what
happens you get a stomachache here where
do you follow up with your stomach
are you cultivating your intuition and I
would say if you're not drinking enough
beer at the Oasis you're not taking
advantage of your education because what
you're gonna do in life is you're always
gonna be gauging people if they're BSS
or not and if you're not cultivating
your human skills they're gonna snow you
you know what I mean
drinking beer is not your enemy drinky
beer and socializing having coffee
you're learning that those are very
constructive moments you're learning is
that a person of BS or can I trust them
what does the behavior that I really
want for my workers if you're always
doing what you didn't do yesterday
you never do ready to get to do today's
work let alone tomorrow's I was always
in the moment looking for opportunities
or as always at Kinkos the guy across
the street looking at my business I was
never really in the business looking out
if you had that vantage point first of
all you your health apparently you deal
with anxiety you're always on the
cutting edge of making it better and I
used to find my job is everything with
beautifully without me but whatever I
did every day I made it better when I
sold my business to these guys in New
York they asked me my biggest
competitive advantage and I said it was
a spark of our workers eyes and I firmly
believe that because anybody can have
those silikal Xerox machines but what he
made the competitive advantage was our
workers had a sense of purpose and
they've got a thousand thank yous from
work customers and they were really
working for the customer and they could
see that relationship so I really spent
all my time nurturing that relationship
and the best definition of management
came from my wife the only reason you
have management is to remove obstacles
not to make obstacles so the only
purpose of a man owner or a manager is
to make workers job simpler and easier
and that's how I conducted my affairs
get a good night's sleep do you know the
secret elixir of life is sleep everybody
wants us natural everything why she's
tracking eyes sleep for a change
you know what you've learned in the date
is imprinted on your brain while you
sleep so if you're not getting a good
night's sleep you're not taking
advantage of your education my mom only
cared about two things saving and
sleeping well it's the only two things I
don't care what you're doing you're
going to bed early and you're getting a
good night's sleep your grades aren't as
important as a good night's sleep the
only thing you have is trust what is the
biggest most important thing a child
wants predictable environment from their
mother
that's called trust what's the only
thing you off with a teenager trust well
say only you want from a worker
trust isn't that isn't doesn't a worker
say well I want to trust that you could
pay me trust is all the qualities of
leadership isn't that when you break
someone's trumpet is that life's all
about trust there's only one work word
and so I had no choice as much as like
paranoid I had to trust people I trusted
people because I wasn't capable to do
things myself we got to incorporate in
the philosophy of our company the values
the real value statement of what we're
all about
the idea of work love and play to be
successful in life you have to have
three things in balance if not how would
you run a 24 hour day business if you
didn't have a balance in your life you
follow me I mean you have a nervous
breakdown if you're just a workaholic
wouldn't you so I think to be successful
you have to have all three and you'll be
more successful if you strive for
balance in your life you make better
decisions
somehow wives are ready ground the hell
out of you you're not a big shot at home
and it's good
so just try to remember make goals every
year for all three work love and play
and it's not you know it's just
important you'll make better decisions
you mansion but I went out and I told
these people that love things
let's go 24 hours a day what they would
say to me Paul
I can't work any harder does it how do
you expect me to keep this thing open 24
hours a day
those are the wrong people they had an
idea of going to people based people and
you can't lead other people unless you
manage yourself and if you don't look
rested nobody wants to follow a leader
that's tired Haggard and miserable I
mean it's just thought a prerequisite
for leadership nobody wants to I think
Obama said a bad job the first month he
looked too dour I agree with devoted for
him if I agree with Bill Clinton he is
not yesterday was inspirational but you
don't want the President of the United
States saying if you don't pass this
legislation you're go off the cliff
wrong he's got to always be cheerful
always uplifting that's what leaders are
supposed to do and then somebody said
well you don't want it you wanted to be
honest no you don't always have to be
honest as a leader you could honestly
say I know this problems over there but
we're still gonna charge forward you
don't have to your leadership is a
different thing it's not you openko
mouna every time remember remember work
love and play you'll be successful
you'll be a better leader
you'd be a more balanced person and
people will respect you more so all you
workaholics drink some beer
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because gyro head ask me to
or Giro head so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know what your Paul's top ten rules
meant the most to you leave in the
comments and I'll join the discussion
thank you so much for watching continue
to believe and I'll see you soon
it's astounding the lack of knowledge of
current events I teach at USC about
class give him a little current events
test in the beginning to students this
last summit last few weeks ago they were
2200 in the SAT types solid A's
native Californians couldn't point
Arizona on the map the guy said oh it's
all sorted in this area how do you not
know where Arizona is do you think that
if you didn't know where her as
otherwise you might have had that
straight-a education but you got in the
lunchroom and they're gonna say fired
what do you think I mean it's just
certain things how many of you love knew
last summer there was a flood in
Pakistan
what are you going to talk about when
you get out in the real world if you
don't have any knowledge of current
events how do you have any way of
assimilating your education in some sort
of context if you don't have a knowledge
of current events
I was always occurring on current events
of Chucky I'd go home at 4 o'clock and
watch the news till 7 maybe I took it to
the extreme but I wake up in the middle
of the night and I watch the BBC for
five minutes to find out what the hell's
gone on since I went to bed I'm really
curious you ever watched it read a good
book you just can't wait for the next
chapter I've never happened to me but I
hear you could
but the news is like that so you heard
it from mr. or fella himself my students
be curious pay attention and watch the
paper read the paper read the news be
involved joining another great stupid
story we got this McKinsey you ever
heard of McKinsey are they here or
something
so I leave the company they spent two
million dollars to study our business
okay I was at this I was talking to this
man and he owned these markets called
its markets in Pennsylvania you ever
seen him okay guy tells me at lunch you
know I can't explain it but we would
close our business from midnight to 6:00
in the morning and because we'd only do
$40 in business but our daytime business
would drop and a half he said I don't
understand why just closing those six
hours would have such an effect on my
daytime business what the guy said tell
you I go to bed I'd like to sleep two
days later I wake up like a bat out of
hell I said one thing I tell you if you
go 24 hours a day your daytime business
doubles is that correct and it's true it
doubled my overhead was the same
everything it was all marginal profit
was that a cool discovery
let's go like this yeah it was a good
discovery
so the bozos get this McKinsey in there
and Mackenzie takes the stopwatch and
says by the way you'll save a bunch of
money closing at 10:00 at night and
opening up at 6:00 in the morning was
that the wrong decision you know the art
of business is seeing what isn't there
anybody can see what's there but the art
doesn't seeing what isn't there did
anybody see the half the customers I
lost because I wasn't there but that's
that's another thing that maybe you guys
don't sees you don't see what isn't
there maybe you should go home and have
some more anxiety there's only one
measure of success in this world you
know what that is your children want to
be with you and their adults don't
forget if you get so busy your children
don't ever want to come home and see you
I don't know if that's really being
successful so uh it's very tricky
marketing to your kids because you ought
to raise I'm gonna be strict but the
same time you wanted to come home for
Christmas how do you do that I mean it's
if you come too strict they don't want
to come home ever your jerk you're too
lenient they become drug addicts I don't